スーパーパティサンディという色界の決勝
で 色界の決勝っていうのは
例えば瞑想して色界の禅定できたならばね
色界の禅定はアビダンマでは 5つありますからね
第1禅  2禅  3禅  4 5とかね
そういう風に 5つあります
ですから もし人が禅定の状態の心を作ったとするならば
それから 禅定状態が壊れないように守らなくちゃいけないんですね
禅定状態っていうのは
心の煩悩が機能しない状態になる
心でまた心の落ち着きがスーッとあるようになる
その状態を守らなくちゃいけない
それと壊れちゃうんです
禅定というのは作っても
また欲が生まれたり 怒りが出たりとかなんとか
その煩悩が表に出て活動しましたならば
もう禅定が消えちゃうんです
ですから 一回禅定ができたならば
それはあるかないか 自分でどのようにわかりますかという
自分の心に全く何か煩悩が出てこない状態
別に瞑想しているわけでもなんでもないかもしれませんだけど
心には怒りも欲も 昏沈睡眠も情動っていうのは混乱の状態も何も出てこなくて
すごい落ち着いて普通に生活しているんだ
で ものを見たってのは決して欲が生まれてこないと
で そういう状態なんですけど
それはもしかするといろいろ世の中で生きていると
もうここ壊れてしまう可能性はあります
で 欲が生まれたら まあもうそこで禅定状態が消えてしまっちゃうんです
そういうふうに この禅定状態を壊さないようにずっと守っておくならば
その人々は確実に亡くなって
色界という次元に生まれるんです
で 色  そういうことは色界同一次元かっていうのは説明前はしましたからね
パタマージャナヴィパークパタマージャナブミヤンパティサンディバワンギチュティヴァセナパッタティ
そこで第1禅定を作った人々がもし死んだとすると
次に生まれるのはもう第1禅定の次元なんですね
ですから 決勝する心は第1禅定のイジクシンなんですね
そこで決勝してから その人のウブンシンも第1禅定イジクシンで
シシンも死ぬ時の心も第1禅定のイジクシンですね
ですから この生命としての基本的な心が第1禅定になるということなんですね
ですから 我々よりは大変な高いレベルの認識を働かせることできるんですね
でも 例えば人間の場合は
ほとんどの人間というのはニインシンで生まれちゃうんですね
ニインイジクシンで ですからこのサンインイジクシンで生まれたならば
もう大変な知恵があって
もう素晴らしい人々なんですけど
そういう人もいないわけないんだけど
大体は少ない 世の中でいる人々はみんな一般的な普通な人々ですから
そこで普通の人々だから
もうウブンシンもニインイジクシンになっちゃうし
死ぬ時もその同じ心になっちゃうんですから
このずっと生きている間では
この土台になっている心なんですね
その心が回転して新しい考え方が生まれたりするんですから
そんなに立派な大胆な考え方を作ったりすることはもうあまりできないかもしれません
サンインで生まれたならば
もう元々の心のエネルギーが強いんだから
で すぐ瞑想したっても
すぐ禅定作られるし 他のことを考えて新しいことを何か考え出そうと思ったら
すごい大胆なことを意見とかね
発見とかすることも もうとても簡単にできるようになるんですね
そういうことで 禅定作ってボンテンに生まれたら
色界に生まれたら ずっとその人々の心が第1禅定イジクシンが土台になります
そのように  第5番目の禅定までわかりやすい
そこでアサンニャサッダっていうのは無常
無想無常 無想無常という生命なんですね
で この無想無常の生命の次元というのは
第4禅定から作る瞑想なんですね
で 人が第4禅定に入ってから
この心の働きは良くないんだということで
心の働きはある程度で止まっちゃうんですね
それだけで煩悩なくなったわけじゃない
そこでアサンニャサットというサンニャーがない人という状態になり
相がない人になっちゃうんですね
で アビダンマテキストでは
まあそれはもう注釈書時代というものは後のテキストたくさんですから
このテキストも随分後の時代であるお坊さんが書いたテキストだからね
そこら辺 その人々には何も心がないんだと
ただ物質だけやと思ってるみたい
この無常常の人々が 物質だけだと思ったら
時計やらカバンやらね
この環状やらね とは何も変わりはないんですけど
そこでまあちょっとどうかなと考えた方がいいんです
そこでないのはサンニャーなんですね
その生命に それは私の解釈ですけど
捨てたければどうぞ遠慮なくに椅子使ってもいいんです
けど ないのはサンニャーなんですね
サンニャーはどうせ日本語でこの相と書きますから
サンニャーっていうのはこの概念でしょう
頭で考えることなんですね
結局は だから何も概念取らないんだと
世の中で外の世界あるんだけど
自分がそれについて反応はしないと
そこで自分の心も我々の心は自分一人勝手にいろんな反応を起こしたりするでしょうに
そういうこともないと
いわゆる我々の俗的な言葉で言えば
心が機能しない状態なんですね
何もサンニャーがないということは
サンニャーっていうのは
例えば壁を見たら なんか壁っていうのは言葉ですけど
言葉ない人でも壁見たら何か見るんですね
例えば赤ちゃんが壁見たって見えるんです
赤ちゃんが一つも言葉を知らないんですね
一つも言葉を知らないんだけど
壁は見て赤ちゃんが何を感じるんですかね
我々も頭の中でいっぱい言葉ありますから
壁だとかね 白いだとかね
黄色いだとか なんとかとか
いろんな概念働きますけど
概念は単語で 言葉で それはサンカーラに入ります
そこでサンニャーっていうのは
言葉現れる以前の働きなんですね
ですから 赤ちゃんが壁見たらそこにサンニャーが生まれる
赤ちゃんには言葉がない
でも我々見る同じ経験が赤ちゃんにも生まれるはずなんです
ですから そこで赤ちゃんが言葉で考えないんだけど
見るものは見るものによって頭が回転する
反応を起こす 聞くものにも頭が反応は起こす
ですから 赤ちゃんみたいに何の一言葉も知らない人間がものを見ると
結構サンニャーは明確に働いている
サンニャーっていうのは
このまあ順番でいえば言葉現れるちょっと前の働きなんですね
でも人間には一緒にいっぱい
瞬時に言葉生まれますけど
頭の中で だからといってこの言葉っていうのは後で判断して作るもので
順番ではまず認識してサンニャーが生まれちゃうんですね
そこでこのサンニャーたくさんあるっていうことは
たくさん物事を知ってるっていうこと
そういうことで この認識するために基本的に必要な働き
そういうサンニャーがないと
いわゆるものは認識しないと受け取れない
対象 眼耳鼻舌身意から入る情報はもう受け取れない
拒否するということで
だからあの人に心はまるっきりないというふうな言い方は
まあちょっと仏教的にはなりたかないんです
心はあるかもしれませんだけど
どうしてもその人とはコンタクト取れないんです
なぜならば情報は受け取れませんから
話中の電話みたいです
いくら電話かけても話中だったらもう受け取れませんね
そうすると電話でコンタクトすることは不可能になっちゃうんです
その人の体 体で考えちゃうと
すべての情報入るチャンネルはね
眼耳鼻舌身意はもう話中状態でもう情報を受け取れない
まあだからまあどうしようもない
まあ何のすることもできないということでも考えられます
大体ナーマとルーパが分かれて存在するということは
それほど仏教では言ってないんですね
物質と心っていうのは別々に働くんだって
大体一緒に働くんです
無色界はまた別な次元なんですけど
だから無色界あるんだから
色のみ界もなんでないかというふうに論理的に考えた可能性もあるし
あるいはアサンニャという言葉は無色だと
色がないと心がないと無心だと解釈した可能性もあります
とにかく何とかの状態でその人々はいるんですね
だから外から情報を受けませんし
内からも情報を取りませんだから反応ないんだから
もう長い時間 もう頭が狂うほど長い時間
その生命にずっと存続することはできるんです
外から全然影響を受けないんだから
例えば金属にしたっても
何でしたっけ この鉄なんかはすぐ壊れちゃうでしょうに
外から影響を受けますから
そこでステンレススチールみたいなものだったら
もう全然平気でいるでしょう
なぜならば酸素に反応しないんだから
もう 何て言いますか の場合はもう腐食することはないんですね
そういうふうなことで
このなんか外からの反応はないし
内からも反応に反応はないんだから
この腐食元素はなくて
長い間いられる ですから
そういう人々がその状態がいいんだと誤解してしまうんですね
それはそれで そういうアサンニャ・サッタという
一応有上の次元があって
それは第四禅定ができた人々にだけ作られる状態なんですね
第四禅定でこの心の働きを抑えると
瞑想では心の働きを成長するんです
成長させるんです もっと集中しようと
もっと力強くしようと
第四禅定まで行った人は
じゃあこの心の働きを抑えておこうと
ということで また禅定を作って
それはこのアサンニャ・サッタという瞑想なんですね
で 何の役にも立たないんだから
仏教では認めてない瞑想ですね
いわゆる煩悩をなくすためには何の働きもしてくれないんですね
で その人々は結晶すると色だけ結晶するんだと
物質だけ結晶するんだとこちらで書いてあるんです
その色もどんな色かちょっとわからないんですけど
アビダンマで考えているのは
ただ物質本の一部存在するんだと
まあそうじゃないと思いますけどね
もうある形の生命が現れますけど
もう生命かとも言えない状態でのもので
それは色界の結晶 そこで色界に生まれた人々の寿命はどれぐらいかと
テーサ ブラッマパーリサッジャーナンデーヴァナン
カッパサタタティヨーバーゴーアーユッパマーナ
遊び子の3分の1なんですね
あの 第1禅定の  第1禅定は3つあるんですね
ブラフマパーリサッジャ
ブラフマプローヒタ マハーブラフマという名前のランク 3つあります
大慈禅定で そこでこのランクの下のランクの場合はアソーギコーワ3分の1
このアソーギとかコーとか
そういう概念がこのずっとこのテキストで説明していますので
そこら辺を読んでみてください
全くその通りじゃないんだけど
そのミャンマーで注釈した時はだいたい自分の好みに注釈しているんです
で そこはこのブッダゴーサ長老の注釈をもとにして
それから経典に出てくるアソーギ
コーの概念も入れて それからもう何のことなくヒンドゥー教の概念も入っちゃってしまって
一つのピッツァみたいなものなんですね
いろんなものを入れて
作ってますからね ストーリーをわかりやすくできるようにできてありますけどね
それは全くその通りでなくても
いくらかはコーという長い時間の次元の概念と
宇宙の現れることやらね
消えることやらね そういうのお釈迦様の言葉なんですね
そちら入ってますからね
サンワッタカッパ ウィワッタカッパ
サンワッタッタハイカッパ
ウィワッタッタハイカッパというこのコー念を 4つに分けちゃうんですね
で サンワッタカッパっていうのは
この宇宙は収縮してね
まあ収縮していく時期
それ長い時期なんですね
そこでサンワッタハイっていうのは収縮出て縮んでしまって
それ以上はもう縮めなくなっちゃうんです
そういう時期でもずっと長い間いて
それからまた広げていっちゃうんですね
で 広げて広げていって
もうこれ以上は広げないという時代に入って
それでまた止まっていて
また収縮を始めるんです
それで終わりじゃないんです
今は我々いるのはウィワッタカッパなんですね
いわゆる広げている時代です
宇宙の物質が だからそういう一つもコー念
コーと言うんですね だからそちらもコーを 4つ考えているんですね
あの縮むコーと縮んで止まっているコーと広げるコーと
いわゆる成長のコーと成長停止のコーと
それもコー念です コー念というかどうかわかりませんけど
コーですね カッパなんですね
それからカッパっていうのは時間のセットというふうな意味で取っているんです
そういうことで 例えばあの犬の寿命は 15年なんですね
それは犬にとってはワンセットなワンライフですからね
ワンセットなんですね
ですから その場合もコーというんです
でも我々から見ればたった 15年だけですけど
人間の場合は 1コーといえば 100年なんですね
人間の寿命は 100年セットで今できているんですから
そういう風に生命の寿命にもコーというんですね
その場合は意味が違う
一つの生命の長さですね
それはアーユカッパというんですね
[紙の音]で このテキスト
この百三十八ページにこのアサンケイエカッパっていうのは
あのカッパは旧講 阿僧祇講
大講四種類に分けて まあその中でこのだいたいこの経典に規定するのはこのサンワッチャ
サンワッチャーヤ イワッチャ
イワッチャーヤという四つの言葉だけなんです
で まあアーユッカッパというのは一般の言葉として出ているし
まあ一応出ますけど まあこちらの説明
それから地球はどのように滅びるかというストーリーもあるはずなんですね
で その場合も経典一つありますね
あの最後に太陽が七つ出るんだと
で 出て地球の生命は地球だけではなくて
全部まとめて まあそれなりに消えてしまうということ
そういうのはまあわからないんですね
本当のところはどうなるかということはね
でお釈迦様 自分の考え方としておっしゃったか
あるいは世の中にそういう考え方あるんだから
何のことなくそれ使ったかどうかはそれもあまりわからないし
たった一つしか経典ないんだから
そこら辺研究もできないんですね
それもお釈迦様その経典を言っているのは
別にこの地球の滅び方を説明してあげようという気持ちでまるっきりなくて
存在は長いよと 輪廻は長いよと
あまりにも苦しみが多いんですよ
ですから早くも今すぐ悟るために頑張れということ言うために
ちょっと例にとっただけのことですから
ですから ストーリーは全くその通りでなくても構いませんし
まあそういうのはもうもう中だから
誰にでも読んでお分かりになると思います
私はテキストの方だけ説明します
それでブラフマプローヒタという二番目の梵天たちが
これ読み方わからない
ボン？ボンポ？ボンポテンシュ
第一戦場を作って この二番目のランクの人々は
まあ 3分の1ではなくて半コーですね
阿僧祇講の半分 阿僧祇っていうのは
10の 140倍 そう 阿僧祇っていうのはこの単なる数字ですね
10の 140倍です 阿僧祇というのはアサンケイエと読むんですね
このアサンケイエっていう言葉は
このもう百 一千万 一億
一兆とかね そういうふうな
このある数字につけてる言葉なんです
その数字 数学ではそれちゃんと数えられてあります
あの百 まあサタ サハスサ
サタサハスとか まあまたいろいろナフタ
ニンナフタ もう最後にアサンケイエが来るんです
それは数字の一番大きなカテゴリーな名前なんですね
まあ日本で言えば一番大きい数字は兆
それ以上もありますか
ん？え？K え？まあ それぞれの文化においていろいろ数字がありますし
まあだから数字ってなん
だからここを計算すると
だいたい 110 のこれぐらいだそうですね
まあそれはまあ数学のことだから
ですから阿僧祇講といえばこう
それぐらいのこう数えちゃうんです
だからコーっていうのはどれぐらいかというと
それなりに変わっちゃうんですね
数字の大きい長さが 寿命そのものもコーと言うし
宇宙が破壊する時間を4分に分けて
それ一つもコーと言うし
そこら辺定めてないんです
そこでマハーブラフマ
大梵天に生まれたら まあ一コーですね
寿命は その場合はコーっていうのはやっぱり人間中心に考えてるんです
人間中心に考えてて 人間のコーは 100年だから 100年住んでるっていう意味ではないんです
こちらで そこで人間の寿命っていうのは
この徐々に増えたり減ったりするんだそうですね
こちらストーリーがあります
何年に一回でしたっけ
百年に一歳ずつですね
減ったり増えたりするんだと
まあどうですかね 百年以内でも増える場合もありますけど
あの まあ一応そういう筋で
まあ例えば人の寿命が十歳になる
十歳で年取って死ぬ それで百年一つずつ一つずつ増えていくと
増えていって ものすごい長い寿命まで
一劫というところまで増えちゃうという
それで計算する場合もあるし
まあもう結局無茶苦茶な説明ですからね
で はっきりしないんです
こうは長いですよと言ったところで
お釈迦様はこの一由旬の山をね
想像してくださいと 一由旬というのはまあだいたい
一由旬といえばまあ一メートル
一キロかな 一キロよりちょっと長いかどうかはわかりません
ちょっとはっきりしない
それもね 昔の由旬って全部この体の長さで計算しちゃったんだからね
ですからはっきりわからない
とにかくまあ一キロぐらいで考えたってもいいし
で 一キロじゃなくて三十里になっちゃいますから
まああとまあ三十キロぐらい
三十か二十八あたりで考えた方がいいんですね
十八キロぐらいと それぐらいの高さがある
幅がある 立方の山 石があったりすると
それはまあ百 百年に一回か
千年に一回か 柔らかい布で一回だけ拭くと
で それでやがてその石が布で拭いたことで消えると
地面と同じになると それぐらいの時間は劫年だと
劫だと 一劫だと というような喩えがあるんですね
で そこをもう想像を絶する時間を考えていることなんですね
ですから まあそれは劫だと考えて
それはその一つ劫が大梵天の寿命なんです
そこで上へ行けば行くほど
小劫天衆は二劫と無量劫天衆は四劫と八劫天衆は八劫で
清浄劫天衆は十六劫になるんですね
それでまあ このパリッターバ・アッパマーナーバ・アーヴァッサル
その三つは第二禅定 アビダンマ的に言えば第二と第三禅定
経典では第二禅定の神々が生まれるところなんですね
いわゆるしょうこうてんしゅ
むりょうこうてんしゅ
はっこうてんしゅ いわゆる光という字が入れているのは
第二禅定 第三禅定の梵天なんです
そこでスヴァという浄という漢字をつけているのは
もうアビダンマでは第三と経典だったら
アビダンマでは第四と経典だったら第三禅定ですね
浄ということを書いています
そこで寿命はどんどんもう伸びていくんですね
三十コーとなって六十四コーになると
これでコーは大コーになっちゃうんです
さらに大きくなるんです
で 一番上 第四禅定を作った人々
あるいは第五禅定を作った人々はアカニッターという梵天に生まれるので
アカニッターというのは
どんな日本語でしたっけ
無齢 無齢天衆かな この無齢天
アカニッターというの言葉の意味は
この まあここ それで終わりと
寿命の次元っていうのはね
喋れるところ いわゆる最高点というところですね
だから寿命の次元が高く
行って行って行って行って行って
もう一番ピーク 一番高いところという意味でアカニッターと言うんですね
ですから この一般パーリ語でも
パーリ語を使っている我々の日常生活の言葉でも
一番高いという意味でアカニッターという言葉を使っちゃうんですね
カニスタっていうのは番目ということで
アカニスタっていうのは番目はないと
いわゆる番目ということで
一番上ということ 一番上の梵天に行ってしまえば
一万六千コー寿命が長いと
まあだいたいそれぐらいで次に進みます
それは考えたっても全然わからないことだから
まあ道徳的に言いたいのは
この もしかするとこの
この永遠な天国はありますよという概念は
人間が昔から持っているし
これからもその概念は消えないんですね
なぜ消えないかというのは
証拠がないんだから 証拠があって喋ると
その概念というのは変化するんです
だから科学は毎日のように変化していっちゃう
科学的な発言というのは
何か証拠があって それによって喋るんです
いい加減には喋れません
何も根拠のないことは言わない
そういう概念というのはどんどん変わっていっちゃうんです
新しい証拠が出たら前の考え方は変わる
で 何の証拠もないということで概念を作ったら
なぜこういう概念があるかというと
それには何の証拠もないんだと
その概念は変えることはできないんです
あ こういうわけで その概念違いますよと
ですから 人間にとっては永遠なものがあるということを言うためには
何の証拠もないんです
そういうことで 永遠という概念は消えません
単なる人間の まあ仏教でいうのは
それは人間の希望だけなんです
ですから このなぜ永遠という概念が生まれるかというと
実感しているのは無常なんです
どんな宗教の人も 死ぬということは確実に実感する
物は消える なくなる お金もなくなる
若さも消える 自分の親戚やら子供たちやら死んでいっちゃうとかね
人々は死ぬわ 世界は変わるわとかね
何一つも止まることはない
納得いかない 嫌でも変わっちゃうんですね
年は取りたくないんだけど
年は取る 病気になりたくないんだけど
病気にはなる ですから
ほとんど存在として自分たちが実感しているのは嫌な変化なんですね
変化していく それまた嫌である
そこで好きな変化は好きなんです
例えば病気になる すごい体が弱くなる
それは変化するんです
無常だから 変化して体痛くない状態になる
その時はすごい喜ぶんです
無常を で 頭悪いんだから無常でよかったと言わないんです
病気が治ってよかったんだと
正しく言えば 無常でよかったということなんですね
無常でなければ 病気になってしまったら
永久的にその病気が続きますからね
そこで弱い子供たちが無常だからどんどん強くなって大きくなるでしょうに
それで弱さから独立へ行くんだから
そこは喜ぶんです 独立したところからもう自分がまた変化してまた行く
そこからはもう悲しむんです
人間っていい加減といえばいい加減なんですね
自分のことにしたっても
二十歳まではどんどん体が美しい方向へ成長するんだから喜ぶんです
そこで 25 30になったところで
もうどんどんどんどん減っていっちゃいますから
そこはもう悲しむんです
でも事実として見ると
どっちでも同じ変化なんですね
だから変化の中で一部の変化は喜ぶ
お金がない人にお金がどんどん仕事をすると
どんどん入ってくると喜ぶ
そこであるお金がどんどん消えていくと悲しむ
同じ法則なんです 持っているお金が消えない法則あるんだったら
お金ない人にお金入る法則もなくなっちゃうんですね
そこら辺頭が明確ではないんだから
人間は すごい感情で物事を見ているんだから
もう理解しない でも世の中にあるのは変化という事実だけ
それはいい方向へ変化しようが悪い方向へ変化しようが
それはその時のアプローチなんですね
決して事実もうしっかりした事実じゃないので
例えば幼稚園の先生にとっては
まあ 5歳になるともう大人でもう卒業させなくちゃいけないんですね
そこでもし幼稚園の先生にすっごい気に入っている子供たちがいたならば
5歳になっちゃうとすごい悲しいんですね
もうもうもう また会えなくなっちゃいますから
だからそちらではそんなふうなことで
小学生の時代になっちゃったら
またそちらの変化はまた違うし
そこでその先生に気に入った学生生徒がいたならば
14歳ぐらいになっちゃうと悲しいと
別れるのはということになるかもしれませんし
ですから どこまで楽しくてどこまで悲しいかということも
そのその時間に合わせて変化するものなんですね
親にしてみれば 18歳になっちゃうと二十歳になってくるともう悲しいんですね
その時は親を離れて出て行っちゃいますから
幼稚園の先生にとってはもう 5歳でも悲しいと
変化は まあそんなもんで
ですから まあ決まってない
例えば人間の寿命の中で 40歳までの変化は悲しくて
40からは 40からの変化は悲しいと決まってない
その時その時の条件によって
もうなんとか決めてしまうもんだから
随分いい加減といえばいい加減なんですね
しっかりしていないところで
ある無常は悲しむ ある無常は楽しむと
そこで悲しむ無常の方が量多いんです
すごい多いんです 楽しむ無常っていうのは少ないんですね
[背景の雑音]で それでもそこでまたすごいへんてこりんなカラクリがありまして
楽しむためには前に苦しみがなければ楽しめないんですね
例えば歩けない赤ちゃんが歩けない状態である
そこでちょっと立ったところで親が楽しむんですね
すごい喜びを感じる その喜びを感じるためには
全く歩けない赤ちゃんが先にならきゃいけないんです
自分でご飯取って食べられない状態で弱い状態でいた赤ちゃんが
どんどん自分の手で取って食べるようになっちゃうと
もう楽しむ ですから 先に苦しみがなければ
次の変化が楽しみだと解釈できないんです
ですから  1万円もらって楽しむ人には
もう先からも 1万円はない状態でいなくちゃいけないんです
1,000万円ある人にとっては
1万円というのは大したことではなくなっちゃうし
ですから 自分に欠けている分によって楽しみが生まれるんだから
まあ本当に客観的に考えると
存在自体は全部悲しいもんなんですね
その中でみんな楽しみがあるんだ
楽しみがあるんだと思ってる
ですから その説明してたのは
人間のこの絶なるこの希望なんですね
永遠ということが それ間違いと
というのが仏教の立場なんですね
だから永遠になったら楽しいかと
論理的になりたたないんです
我々楽しいというのは
無常に楽しいという 苦しみの状態
無常だから変化するでしょうに
それに楽しいという そこで変化止まったところで楽しいという証拠はないんです
で 私たちの体は変化止まったと
言ったら楽しいっていう証拠はないんです
変化止まったと言ったら
人間にあなたの体の全部変化止まるならばいいですか？といきなりいいですよって言うかもしれませんけど
もっと智慧のある人に聞きたければ
例えば年取るのは止まってもらいたいとかね
老化するのは止まってもらいたいとぐらいはもう言うかもしれません
一部だけ でもお腹空くのはずっとあってほしいと
で 体の変化止まったならば
ものは見えなくなる それも変化だから見えるでしょうし
音は聞こえなくなる 全部感覚は止まる
もう機能しなくなる いわゆるミイラになったことなんですね
化石になったことなんですね
体自体 体自体化石になったら
もうそれでもう何百万年でも持てるんですけど
で その状態楽しいかと
と考えてほしいんですね
でも人間楽しいのは無常だからなんですね
それなのに永遠な状態があって
こんな悲しみはその状態になるんだっていうのは
ただの人間の妄想概念で
人間の希望概念ですね
ですから 永遠というものはなかなか消えない
で もしかするとその概念に仏教でちょっとケチをつけるために
数字を随分長い長いもう人間に想像できないほどの時間感覚をとって
これでもかこれでもかと
だから天界の天人の寿命を見ても
何億年でしょうに 人間で考えれば計算いくらかできますけど
それさえ人間にわからないんだから
そこで梵天に持っていったら
それこうという概念に持っていって
それまたまあ無量寿梵天になっちゃったら
どれぐらいでしたっけ
ソーラセカップ  16000光年
だから光一つも宇宙の時間だから
だから無量寿天 無量寿なんとか天にアカニッタという天梵天にいる人々が
この宇宙が現れて消えるのを何回見ていますか？何回見ているかというと
やっぱり 16000回見ているんですね
宇宙が現れて消えていくのは現れて消えていくのは
で 仏教ではそれでも 16000回終わったらあいつは死んじゃうんだと
その次元で ということを言いたがっているんですね
そのために重要ということを言うんです
死ぬんだと いくら長くたっても
で それでもう一つ インド人はよくブラフマンやらね
そういう神々にお祈りしたり
我々救ってくれてまえとかね
助けてくれてまえとか言ってるんですね
神々に頼る ヒンドゥー教だったら神々よりは修行やらヨガやってる人々はやっぱり梵天に頼る